there isn't why I'm no longer Minister
is because I would not sign another loan
agreement that would give us another
extend and pretend loan on condition of
increasing corporate tax rates
increasing v80 rates in an economy which
is completely broke and whether there is
no credit and there is no investment so
in answer to your question my heart
aches and my mind constantly is trying
to to come up with questions with
answers to the questions such as yours
as to what needs to be done
unfortunately there's no way of mending
Greece without restructuring and
recalibrating the European Union and the
European monetary union in particular so
this is what really matters now there's
a quote in your book a debt maybe a debt
but an unpayable debt does not get paid
unless it sensibly restructured that is
the only way for it is as you see it
absolutely look when you have an
insolvency you cannot overcome it so
more debt especially when the debt the
new that comes from conditions of
shrinking nominal incomes it a 10 year
old can agree with and and this is this
this is a tragedy of Greece over the
last 10 years or so so take general
models it wouldn't exist today if its
debt was not the structured so at that
that is unsustainable will be a
structure the question is will it be
restructuring it a therapeutic manner or
in a catastrophic manner so far in
Greece it was a lot looking at what's
happening in the United Kingdom this
upcoming vote on the praxis how does
that change your optimism does it does
it mute it in some way if the UK were to
vote to leave how less optimistic
worried about the future of the European
Union oh I campaign in Britain against
breaks and one of the arguments is that
it's a huge error on both sides of the
argument as to whether they remain
campaign and the leave campaign to think
that the European Union is something out
there on the other side of the british
channel and then it's simply a question
of whether the brits want to stay in or
out whether in its like a golf club do
you want to be a member or not it's this
is a completely false view the european
union is not a given the european union
is working progress and indeed it is
disintegration in plug
and a brexit would speed up this
disintegration and the speeding up of
this disintegration will create a
gigantic deflationary force a vortex
within continental Europe which will
consume buttons I get here the Brits can
vote to get out but they cannot believe
the mess that will be left behind you
write about the role of central banking
and I think it's particularly
interesting to think about at this
juncture saying that you can't have a
central bank that is a political totally
technically based and yet we hear from
Janet Yellen all the time she's entirely
dependent on the data we depend on the
central bank here to act in a political
way in light of what's happening at the
Fed at the European Central Bank with
the Bank of Japan what do you say in
terms of how these these entities behave
versus what they're able to do when it
comes to politics what you need to be
data and empirically based if you're a
senator banker of course you need to be
the question is can you be a political
of course not look at the Fed has a dual
mandate it has a mandate of price
stability and keeping an employment
below a certain level gross now how
exactly do you balance those two pillars
this is a political decision so you may
have independence of the fed from
Congress from the White House and that's
probably good thing to have but to argue
that the Fed is making these decisions
without any political gender is simply
to run in the face of reality money can
never be a political